I was was quite into having my own style
I guess I just actually for teachers
like sewing but I liked what you could
do with it I always had something quite
different than you and I sort of like
that just became very much what I did is
I went into fashion
[Music]
Yahoo scream I used to go and buy fabric
in the daytime with my pocket money and
then make something in the afternoon
willing wear it out in the evening I was
always very observant about how people
look
they wore how they express themselves
hence you know be humanly romantic there
was a strange and Boy George and Spandau
Ballet you know we were the Blitz kids
quite influential at the time and we all
went on to do something quite creative
with their lives great time to be a
fashion student I just slowly became
aware to costume houses there was a
whole side of design that I didn't
really know about I did realize I love a
narrative I like the fact that you use
costumes to tell a story and to create
character and the more I did it the more
I realized that something that I really
really enjoyed you know the story you
know what they're doing you know what
their relationships are you need to show
that somehow in cloth in a period piece
you can look at replicas what did they
wear in Holland in black you know you
have the evidence and then you can play
within that in was friend is much harder
in a way because you have to make it up
I just York all the time even if I'm not
working on something I'll make
scrapbooks when I see an image I'll just
stick it in like a Circe file or
whatever and I'll just keep putting
things and it just might be a texture so
when it comes around to starting a game
I'll have a little sort of file of ideas
which just might influence the way it
goes and it often happens again god I
forgot about that that would be quite an
interesting way but also what you've
done before sort of informs you where
you need to go
[Music]
designing a series like this cluster has
come from script that guides you then
you start building up a picture of how
this person lives and what influences
them as if they're on the coast they
can't raise and they can buy and they
can become much more flamboyant there's
competition because there's more than
one armor or more than one dressmaker
it's winter so what do people do in the
evenings
well they embroider you have to
balance that with the other characters
around them and consider the set colors
and it just evolves I enjoy doing the
solving very much Arion Valley and was
enthroned Searcy because it just really
become very strong I like the initial
designing and planning and coming up
with the sort of ideas for characters
working as a team to make that happen
when you finish a film or a TV series I
think that's it that's your body of work
you feel like you've really contributed
something
hey youtubers Red Alert new Game of
Thrones let's break it down there is a
new round of the giveaway it's for the
HBO now subscription all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so the really cool
thing here is they talk about how they
tell the story of Game of Thrones with
the clothing it's got some of the best
costumes of any TV show anywhere in the
world but it's all customized for each
of the characters so like she singles
out Cersei Sansa Daenerys how they've
slowly risen to power the way they wear
clothing changes like if you have access
to certain materials you'll just make
nicer more flamboyant things
Cersei is Queen now so obviously there's
the Queen's Guard all their armor has
changed the mountain is the most visible
example of that I love the way that you
see him without his helmet on here so it
just makes you wonder with morbid
curiosity whether or not they're going
to show him in the light of day without
that helmet on I feel like he's scarier
with it on but you get a brief look at
him when he's going in but set to end
Ella like he slowly takes it off and the
camera pans away and it's really dark so
you can't really tell you see now that
Daenerys has come back to Dragonstone
she's wearing Targaryen colors everyone
around her
you see Tyrion walking on the beach here
after they land you also saw him in the
previous promo with a slightly different
costume so all the characters with a few
exceptions get a couple big costume
changes
Sansa looks like she's going to be
wearing super dark black for most of the
season I love the stuff that she's in
and just implies that she's headed in a
darker direction they might not be able
to do Lady Stoneheart on the TV show but
they're definitely going to push salsa
in that direction even Jaime has a
slightly different outfit on I couldn't
tell of him standing here with these
suspenders and that weird neck piece was
just waiting between shots and these are
his plain clothes or if he's actually
wearing this underneath his armor and
he's just standing around talking to
Cersei because you see her and
behind-the-scenes footage is walking
around the map room with the camera
rolling on her with this other person
here still trying to complete the rest
of this big floor map for her you get
more of close shots of her engraving of
the Lannister gear the old King's Guard
gear they even show you a lot of
up-close shots of Littlefinger's outfit
with the sigil of the mockingbird
there's just the sigil of his house just
like the Starks have the direwolf on all
their clothing
you see Sophie Turner looking like she's
throwing a snowball at someone it's
hard to tell if the cameras on here here
or if this is between shots and she's
just having fun because look you see the
hound here grab a handful of fake snow
and throw it just laughing like oh yeah
that is definitely not happening on
camera just looking at the hound
this is his default face right here does
that stank base like he isn't going to
take anybody in speaking of which -
sir davos who's always so serious you
see him laughing here between tags just
looking at that canon camera did not
know that they sold canon cameras up in
the north during that period but you see
more of aria that looks like she's still
relatively close to the twins most of
this greenery if she was closer to
Winterfell would be covered with snow
it'd be way more sparse it's way too
nice looking even where Daenerys is here
there's a lot of greenery - I wonder
what this is going to look like in the
final version of the film there isn't a
whole lot of stuff that grows at
Dragonstone but obviously because we're
going to be spending so much time there
we'll see a lot more parts of the island
that we haven't seen before but like you
see Tyrion walking out here on this big
field so there is some greenery it's not
just all black rock you get a better
look of her walking around the map table
and then one of my favorite
behind-the-scenes shots here is of her
sitting on the throne with this black
rock around here like they've carved it
into the rock here this is one of the
only rooms that we haven't seen in
Dragonstone before we've been down to
the dungeons we've been to the living
quarters we've been to the map table
room but we haven't ever been in the
throne room
maybe Stannis just didn't care to sit
there but it sounds like he was more
comfortable around that table - just
because most of the time we saw him
there those scenes were him planning
during the war of the five kings so it's
not like he had much caused a whole
Court in at throne room the way that
Cersei would at King's Landing but you
see Sansa down in the crypts of
Winterfell
she spent a lot of time down there
during season five just because she's
been gone for so long it's a very
important place for her family but it's
also a place to get away from Ramsay I
don't think we ever saw Ramsay down in
the crypts you get a shot of a
Littlefinger that looks like he's
sneaking around at Winterfell I love how
he always looked so shady but you get a
better shot of the little bear you see
Brienne in furs and then if I'm not
mistaken this actually looks like Jon
Snow is actually on that same plane
where Tyrion is looking at the dragon
rise up this might be where he's
actually a dragon stone so let me know
it's kind of hard to tell where do you
think that Jon Snow is
ending right here it could be outside of
Winterfell there is grass that grows
near Winterfell but it's kind of hard to
tell because it's so out of focus in the
background but like he's one of the few
characters that's not going to get that
many costume changes aside from the
wildling gear that you see him in later
in the trailer so like they show a
couple of the other costumes they show
some of the wildling costumes that
they're building you see a lot of green
Tyrel colors they're going to be
fighting with Daenerys as army but aside
from the quick shot at Theon and then
Cersei walking around in her inner
chambers there's not a whole lot else
here but one of the other coolest things
is Samwell inside the Citadel you can
see he's clearly reaching for a book
really high up on a shelf and you can
spot some of the green screen because
the Citadel is this huge high tower
obviously they're not all going to build
that for Game of Thrones so they just
build these big bookshelves and they
just fill the rest out with CG but let
me know right now which set are you most
excited to go to obviously we're going
to see a whole bunch more of the
citizens and we've seen before but I
feel like the big reveal this season is
going to be Dragonstone just because
Daenerys is there they're going to be
filming it in so many different ways
we've seen King's Landing for the last
six seasons we've seen a lot of
Winterfell for the last six seasons but
we've really only seen a couple of the
big rooms and Dragonstone and it is a
really big castle we haven't even seen
where the Dragons live beneath the
cliffs leave all your requests for Game
of Thrones bonus videos in the comments
below we're going to get another big
trailer in the next couple weeks and
then we'll probably get more of these
behind the scenes in between that so
there'll be a lot more promos a lot more
footage dropping between now and the
actual season coming so new Game of
Thrones posting later this week I'll say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Jacqui Porter is please private
message me so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
you can click here for my Tyrion video
and you can click here for all my other
promo videos thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys tonight